Je suis devenu un gars de combat après que mes parents
ont été agressés et tués en rentrant de
l'Opéra, alors je vous dis les gars de ce
bâtard malade ensuite leurs cartes de crédit
sur des sites porno J'espère juste que nous aurons la
chance de dire bonjour à ce gars un jour
pour que je puisse  personnellement faire léviter son âme
de son corps oh mon dieu Marty ouais je
sais que j'ai reconnu ta voix non je ne
sais pas de quoi tu parles je
ne sais pas chérie nouveau mec hé c'est moi
Dave Dave pourquoi es-tu  habillé comme un
gros cul parce que je suis un gros cul vous vous
connaissez tous les deux oh ouais comme depuis que nous
avions cinq ans c'est un peu à propos de vos
parents qui se font tuer